our political editor beth rigby reports
on a pm under pressure and a cabinet
revolt
is it time to come clean mr jarvis
time to come clean and clear out this to
be the health secretary's last walk up
this street into cabinet
as what was meant to be a routine weekly
gathering morphed into something very
different
look at their faces
nothing routine or typical about any of
this good evening i'm just gonna go
spend some time with my family sajid
javid tonight heading home after
quitting government and leaving the
prime minister in peril in a letter to
boris johnson mr javid said the tone you
set as a leader and the values you
represent reflect on your colleagues
your party and ultimately the country
but the country needs a strong and
principled conservative party and the
party's bigger than any one individual i
served you loyally and as a friend but
we all served the country fast when made
to choose between those loyalties there
can only be one answer
and just minutes later the chancellor
giving his answer to rishi sanak
resigning to from government saying in
his letter to mr johnson the public
rightly expect government to be
conducted properly competently and
seriously i recognize this may be my
last ministerial job but i believe these
standards are worth fighting for and
that is why i am resigning i'm sad to be
leaving government but i've come to the
conclusion that we cannot continue like
this
a government for months embroiled in
sleaze and scandal be it parties in
number 10 during lockdowns
or a porn watching mp the latest
controversy was over this man chris
pincher forced to resign from government
over accusations of sexual harassment
made all the worse after it turned out
that despite number 10's denials the
prime minister knew of a past formal
complaint all along and appointed him
still prime minister do you accept it
was a grave error to appoint chris
pincher to your government yes i think
it was a mistake and i apologize for
for it i think in in hindsight it was
the wrong thing to do i apologize to
everybody who's been badly affected
by it and i just want to make absolutely
clear that there's no place in this
government for
anybody who is predatory or who
abuses their position of power did you
want to joke though pincher by name
pincher by nature well what i can tell
you is that
if i look at the background of this and
why i regret it so much is that uh
about three years ago
there was a complaint made against chris
pincher in the foreign office the
complaint was was
cleared up he apologized uh it was
raised with me
uh in uh orally there was a i was i was
briefed on wanted
had happened and
you know if i had my time again
i would think back on it and uh
recognize that
he wasn't going to learn
any lesson he and he wasn't going to to
change cabinet ministers even those most
loyal to the pm will be tonight
reflecting on whether change is
necessary
how long can he continue to win do you
think that boris johnson will be prime
minister by the end of the year oh i'm
going for walpole woolhole did 21 years
but nick and i should like to are you as
confident
okay let me put another are you as
confident tonight as you were 24 hours
ago that boris johnson will remain prime
minister
well
we'll have to see if he can win
elections but some say another election
is necessary now
we need a fresh start for britain
we need a change of government and this
government is collapsing the tory party
is corrupted and changing one man at the
top of the tory party won't make any
difference he won't fix the problems
let's have a fresh start for britain
let's have a real change of government
can boris johnson survive this has been
the issue that has been debated by his
enemies and his allies alike for months
and the question tonight is whether
these two bombshell resignations could
be the moment that decides the matter of
his future for now boris johnson's
determined to carry on but his
leadership is in free fall as is his
command over his government and the
parliamentary party rivals are circling
mps are mobilizing to try and trigger
another confidence vote in a pm who's
never looked as imperiled as right now
the pm tonight acting fast to try to
move ministers around and regain some
grip but all of this is out of his
control and now no sense he'll ever be
able to pull it back beth rigby sky news
westminster
well let's get more now then from our
political editor beth rigby who joins me
here in downing street well certainly
the prime minister moving quickly to
make it look like business as usual but
this was big beth big
that's right anna the prime minister
tonight trying to get a handle a grip on
this crisis appointed nadim zahawi his
education secretary promoting him to
chancellor and steve barkley his chief
of staff and cabinet minister appointing
him to health but it can't distract
from what is the worst day i think
for him
since becoming prime minister the
confidence vote was bad but there really
was an expectation that he would win it
he when it won it less well than we
expected but he did win it this is two
bombshell resignations from two heavy
hitters in the party two potential
would-be contenders and it's not just
that this is a night of resignations
there's been seven more resignations in
junior post be it trade envoys or junior
pps's who advise ministers there have
been a number of mps coming out to say
they no longer uh support the prime
minister he is in free fall and yes
many in the cabinet are rallying around
him but make no mistake this civil war
in the party is now really blown open i
spoke to a former cabinet minister
tonight i said what do you think what's
your verdict he said he's finished so
nadine so is nadim i said how long would
you give boris johnson he said a few
days another tory back venture who had a
one-on-one with the prime minister today
told a colleague of mine he lied to my
face
today
he lied to my face before he lied to my
face today he's an effing liar it is
absolutely
horrible within the party another mp
i've just been talking to about the
likelihood of another confidence vote
basically holds the view that enough mps
will call for it they will go to sir
graham brady and ask for it and if the
prime and and graham brady goes to tell
the prime minister that mps want him to
resign and if he doesn't do they force
another vote that is where they are at
so boris johnson can appoint new cabinet
ministers and try to get back onto the
front
foot but at the moment the question here
is how long can he
survive the idea that he can ultimately
survive i would say tonight is fading
fast beth will talk to you again a
little later it's changing fast is it
not beth thank you very much indeed